now for the weather from Bridgeport
Nebraska its Cloudy with rain and a
chance of lightning oh my god the car
was just struck by lightning oh my god
this is storm chaser John persons
closely observing the awesome power of a
million volts of lightning
probably one of the best things about
the video is his reaction to getting hit
by lightning he absolutely freaks out so
why has the lightning come down to earth
through John's car enlightening you
create a large amount of voltage which
is generated in the clouds and this
creates a lightning bore which feels its
way to ground as it's feeling its way to
ground it sees John's car with this
antenna sticking out this is a great
path to ground so it reroutes itself to
the car and all the energy in the
Lightning port flows through the antenna
through the car to ground a ham radio
antenna this is what's left of it as you
can see this design this is pretty fresh
John's car is toast but why isn't he
John survives because electricity will
flow through the metal car instead of
through John's body because that's a
better path to ground long human bodies
are conductive but they're not nearly as
conductive as metal is
we can get hit by lightning and killed
by lightning but compared to a car we're
not very good at conducting electricity
so the car will always come worse off
so is it safer to stay in your car
during an electrical storm the moral the
story is if you're trapped in a
thunderstorm one of the best places to
be is inside your car with the door shut
let the lightning hit the outside your
car and it'll go away instead of
standing outside and getting hit by
lightning